so ukraine was able to force thousands
of russian troops out of the kharkiv
region in a matter of days but along the
border with russia the shelling
continues unabated
dw's nick connolly has been to meet
people rebuilding their lives to the
sound of artillery fire
less than a week ago this was a journey
best made in a tank
now just an hour's drive separates
with its restaurants and metro from
villages just emerging from six months
of occupation
here within sight of the border the
outnumbered russian army held on the
longest throwing everything it had at
advancing ukrainian forces most the
locals didn't stick around leaving pets
and livestock behind
sidlana is one of just a handful of
residents left on her street which has
been without power and without phone
signal for the past six months and as of
last week without a roof
i came out of the cellar and after the
bang it seemed like everything was all
right i had to go down again and when i
left everything was gone the door the
window and the roof all just gone
the blast wave took it straight off all
that's left are my skis
and it wasn't the first time after two
previous hits sit lana was able to patch
things up but not this time
many of her neighbours had it worse
a boy next door was killed and two
houses down the road there was a
neighbor a veteran of the soviet army
he was sitting in his yard and out of
nowhere a piece of shrapnel hit him in
the forehead and killed him
the russians kept asking me why i didn't
leave i turned it around and asked them
why they came in the first place i've
been here for 39 years
a light sleeper svetlana tells us she
hopes she'll wake up in time the ceiling
does end up falling down
like millions of other ukrainian
refugees svetlana's daughter and
grandson are now in poland
with her family scattered she relies on
her neighbor michaela for help
but six months of occupation have taken
their toll on him as a man of fighting
age michalo was constantly in the sights
of the russian army
i only left the house during the day
you just have to keep your head down
the first time the russians picked me up
was in april
a few times a month they would get me in
again
i still have the marks from the bullets
they shot at my legs
they were obsessed with finding out
where my brother was in the military and
where his documents were hidden
michalo says his father was taken away
by the russians in march since then all
trace of him has been lost on both sides
of the border
this is just some of the shrapnels that
lana has collected in her living room
just in the space of the last few days
with no end in sight to shelling along
the border why not take this chance to
get out
she tells us ukrainian troops offered to
take her to kharkiv in their tank her
response was simple
not until i've repaired my roof
for more analysis of the situation on
the ground we are now joined by marina
myron she is an honorary research fellow
in the defense studies department center
for military ethics at king's college in
london thank you so much for joining us
on the program
now we've seen
impressive gains by the ukrainian army
in the last few days can we expect
something similar in the near future
that is correct we have seen some really
impressive offensive capabilities in the
north so in the region of issum which is
the
park oblast
close to russia's border
however we're still seeing some
difficulties in the south so essentially
the reason for the success um it was
a surprise to the russian forces as they
have moved their troops to the south
expecting the uh so called her son
offensive however they couldn't hold the
ground in the north and the amount of
ukrainian troops deployed for the
northern offensive was outnumbering
whatever was left there of the russian
forces so the best they could do
was retreat to save manpower
right now the question is that was a
tactical game for the ukrainian military
however they need to hold that ground
and so it is too early to tell how that
will turn out
that being said they definitely
undermined russia's plans in in military
tactical sense now it's interesting that
you would say that especially the last
bit because the russian president
vladimir putin just said that the
counter-offensive that came as a
surprise as you say won't change
russia's plans that russia has so far
not deployed its full forces and he
added quote we aren't in a rush
what do you make of that
well obviously it was a slap for russia
in a tactical sense and the whole idea
was to be able to surround slovanska and
chromatorsk and repeat the lysid chance
scenario now on the ground they will
have to regroup and change their plan
and they're seeing obviously the
continuous push in the curson region and
that is strategically
much more important um obviously there
needs to be kind of some diplomatic exit
for putin in order to keep the morale
high of his forces on the ground
and of course they are trying to
mobilize more forces right now as we
speak however occur son is difficult in
terms of logistical support to the
troops so it remains to be seen how that
plays out
so marina just briefly if you would
looking at
the other side the west
can ukraine
handle this offensive or the
counter-offensive on its own does it
need more support from the west and will
it get it
that's a great question because um
obviously the counter offensive took
place now six months into the war the
ukrainian forces have received an
enormous amount of help from the west
and both in military equipment as well
as in training
yet we have to think about the seasons
and about the fact that the winter is
approaching and about ukrainian economy
which
is
about to crumble according to the world
bank they need
349 billion
for recovery of the ukrainian economy so
on the one hand they have to sustain
that war effort on the other hand they
will have to provide for the population
and we have seen that russia has been
targeting critical infrastructure and
we've seen blackouts throughout the
country so that makes things more
complicated and we have a bigger picture
with you know the russian gas and oil
supplies in europe so um that money has
to come from somewhere as a help that
ukraine needs and in how far european
countries
are willing to sacrifice the good of
their own citizens to help ukraine
remains to be seen that's that's the big
question indeed uh marina myron an
honorary research fellow in the defense
studies department center for military
ethics at king's college in london thank
you so much
thank you